[Music playing]
Eric Fromling: With you Eric Fromling,
I work as a developer of what is known as independent games and has been able to manufacture
The whole game itself is called BombSquad.
I started writing BombSquad out of sheer hobby and during that
I graduated from the Institute of Arts.
I was writing it just for fun with my friends
During our meetings to spend a pleasant time.
I adore model innovation,
Therefore all the contents of the game, whether characters or scenes,
Previously set up in reality, then added
To the game, giving this game a unique character.
For years it has been a hobby.
But a few years ago, I decided to start
So I see what I can do.
Now I am earning my living from this.
Before Player Analytics appeared, I was feeling the way
Like the blind and guess what the players are doing on my game,
I guess the reason for their spending a long time
And in anything that spends their time on the game,
But without my will.
But when I started using this tool, I started to see my way
In the best way.
I suddenly discovered a low level of fruit,
Where I can improve the retention or improvement of the player
Income from the game.
BombSquad is essentially a multiplayer game, but 90%
Those who play would prefer the style of individual play.
This helped me a lot in focusing my efforts
And add more content and activities to them
Players in this mode of the game.
I knew from Player Analytics that players are investigating
Earning more than spending in the game,
So I was able to rebalance my economic calculations
And the introduction of a significant positive change on my earnings.
This in turn earned me 140% of the profit rate per user,
In addition to 67% of the profit rate per user paying a fee.
When you look at the player progress chart,
I also discovered that players are having difficulty in
Skip the second or third level of the game.
The degree of difficulty was great.
So I checked it out to make a balance.
You've added an easy situation.
After that, I saw an increase of 3.6 times the number
Levels completed by players,
Which helped to increase the retention rate of players.
The presentation tool is important in many ways.
From a face that I use as a tool to test efficiency.
After you've submitted the game, I can see the Event Viewer to make sure
Of that users' frames are still good every second,
And that everything is going well in the game.
There is something else I have learned from the event viewer
I use very long training materials.
Where he was skipped by many after about 10 seconds.
You have benefited greatly from Player Analytics
What made me distinguish between right and wrong in what I do,
And then managed to adjust the compass
Making it financially profitable.
The most important advice to developers
To put content,
And explore the places of error and watch the numbers,
Using tools like Player Analytics.
You can then correct the errors and try again.
I also recommend the importance of perseverance to achieve the goals in the end.
[Music playing]